金くれアルバイトでかすげー
こんにちははじめ社長です今のコメントに
もあったんですけどみなさんお金稼ぎたい
ときどうしてますか学生時代の時の話なん
ですけどバイト結構いろんなのよっており
ますで皆さんっているもですけどコンビニ
でもバイトしてましたし
家庭教師もやってましたまたお祭りの屋台
のおにいさんもやってましたテレビ局の
スタッフだのケーブルうまく仕事どれも
やってたしあとイベントスタッフが言って
ましたね結構いろんな場合で実は行って
おりまして意外とアルバイターでしたすん
な味の社長もバイトをしなくなって約56
年かな約56年バイトカラーエンドない
生活してるんですけども私ふと思いました
アルバイトのいろんな仕事があると思うん
ですけども俺も視聴者さんの皆さんも白
ないような不思議というかそんなの5倍と
なるだっていうあまり知られていない
ちょっと薄い gb ですね今回体験して
いきたいと思いますはいたまには家の人に
も言ってるんですけども二等倍としたく
なることあるんですよ昔 by 通して
ない人なら分かると思うけど楽しいせば
いいと休憩時間だったり viper 取り
友達とかやっぱり公園の花さにするのは
ちょっと楽しかったのもあるのでちょっと
懐かしいというか久々にそのバイトの感覚
を味わえたらいいなと思いつつ僕もまで
聞いたことのないようなそれいっぱいと
なーみたいな存在せ出せなかったような
回答もありますので今回はそんなあまり
知られていないような特殊なアルバイト
いろいろちょっと私を体験していきたいと
おもいます下の子ですでは早速やってみ
ましょう
軽いんん
あ
ん
これが決まった
[音楽]
こんにちはいいえ
こんにちは
いかわいい
登ってきたん
ん
[音楽]
ブーバポリマー
ヌー
[音楽]
ブーブー1人も来てくれない以下あー
ぬーんですけど僕が緊張している母でそれ
があるかもしれないんですけどお母さんて
ね通わないんですねはいなので青色の色を
識別できるというふうに言われてるんです
けどを得ることを聞いているかちょっと
わからないところがあったりするのでもう
ん張博直色みたいな力が入ってからたり
するので星かしたら色々なはいうかも知れ
そうなるほどえっ私はお得なので
よろしければで pro あれでます付け
をしていればいい
レアとポイントが足を伸ばしていただい
たりします
するとお母さんが怒ってうざいましてい
ますなーんだけどのピン式になってくるの
で徐々に徐々
遊びに行こうっ
へっするのが録っても大好きなのでこんな
感じて自ら膝の上にをやってしまうって
いう感じでやってきますかわいいですれ
可愛いユ23良ければ保全することが
いっぱいありますから v23今日
よろしくお願いマジよろしくお願いします
ディズニーですよお腹のところを書いて
あるが気持ちよくて
これそんなプリプリしてるんだデリング
です
これも気持ちいいのが終わっちゃうてまた
立ち上がっちゃうんでウイうまくそこはと
パー書をピクニックデーコン
ヌースまずはしっかりと仲間の名前を
覚えることからでね何
さてはちょっと覚えたらどうかのテスト
よろしくお願いますお願いしますほたる
ちゃんこのが海くん
ベリー
4成田猪瀬生みたいな格好いい子が羽座
あなたがバナナ
あってみるぞやっほい
えっこれで覚えてるってすごくなって働け
ます間違いなかったのだからぜひぜひ
宜しくどうぞ
ブーブーブーブー do を順番に印所が
下しあ入っちゃいましょう
[笑い]
ブーブー
て西3
はいそうです背面頑張ろうねはいいき
ましょう
一つ一つ降っていていた
よろしいですね結構
機微に早いなんていていってください
ジョジョ花花花ni
[拍手]
続いてまだ云々するのでぜひ急いで脱脂し
て態度や海に元に飾るん
ani
どうぞ沿った
[音楽]
味噌ですか
指にこれ
ゼロですねー
これずううううううっ
ましたこちら羽田ねー
はいはい
lebanon
pai赤や pip 風を生み出すはい
う呼べるん
車間月はいこちらがぜ兄ちゃんっ
植木
ではこれから部半ばにご飯の準備を一緒に
お手伝いいただきたいなと思うんですが
こちらのポップは惑星首のボタン道で
こちらが完走組のボタンとお願いをしたい
と思いますみなさんの数の4弾も大きい声
で人の手が足りないだろ
彼がいまして
準備社長の交換をしていただきたいなと
はいかしこまりました是非負担等ではい
mulberry が率いるぞ
記事と同じ側の山できるんですよどこに
だって
以上の3個味噌はいじゃ
ここからが皆さん館すでにから順番に深さ
にを足元に連れていくのでぜひ頃者らの
中間にご飯をあげるように入っていただき
たいと思います
[拍手]
ブーブー第3なぁよしよし違う違うあーた
地学
タッキーと味噌だよタッチ音
京都
よしよしです
[音楽]
いやーいっ
ブーブー言っ
銘茶大人さん
[音楽]
ブーバれました
なつかしっられました母みたいなお話とか
皆さんの魅力を的なのが始まりましたん
例えてマイクロブタかでを敷かれたんです
[笑い]
が私が
例が多い会社ですいいで何か雑誌とかにも
出て話題になってたんだ明書よ
んじゃだったんですかなるほど
まず始める初めて来ましたどっどうですか
ん
はい犬飼ってるんですけど犬とが全然後ろ
にとって
こんな日声にびっくりすごいやばすぐに
言うと全然はすごいん
楽しんでいってくださいん
看護
ピグミーさんです1枚お願いします
持っていた
県産一番読めません
いただきますございます
大変だこれ
歌さんがはちゃん写ってると思うんです
けどここからスピブ23を見ていただいて
2さんを誘導するっていうことを行って
いただきますはい日23宜しくお願
アイデアたちへ最初は私が食べ5 s と
か思ってもらう大丈夫なのでそれでこの
こすりながら
海外であるか
結構やった結果などを膝の上に続きネペタ
ターンを
[音楽]
でしょっ
早ジャズ2
[音楽]
me知っています
tad した
入れ
[音楽]
ません
[笑い]
ブーバー
福治言ったかブタさん竜巻決められている
大丈夫ですよ
他がこの a さんから2人と受け
やっぱり焦っちゃって
ひやー近くというの
ケンカした時のすぐ取れるスタッフさんの
速度 a paso a
あれこそなれるが彼こそができたほんと
なんか夫婦の子の可愛さの中でしっかり
締めるとかそれというかそしてばかげなの
でお客様がいらっしゃるという接客て部分
もすごいしっかりされてたんでいい職場だ
なというか
ちょっとしてねえっ
夏合わせていただいてすごい[ __ ]
ジェジュン時でしたありがとうじゃよ
ください8本当に凄いですでき揚力が穏当
にメダンでまず歌桜 a 7匹の覚えるっ
できないっぜひアンカー顔じゃ状態を剥い
を得て記憶法だ
けど不況ということですそうですね言葉な
のですよねバンナ金か好きそうだったんだ
ね県が4月からねゼリーちゃんすごいもう
すごいなんだか名前をぐるっとかブタさん
の国情をなおのコーンを知ってもらうとか
というところからスタートしてくるんです
けどほんと今短時間でキュッと濃厚されて
いることをしてくださっているエイブル
本当にだ
入ってください鈴木将義通ったのぜひ遊び
たいお客さんと初戦で遊びに来たして
くださいぜひ思っています
入って行けです今回なんとですね
スペシャルゲストをお呼びしております
あのかの有名なスペシャリストの方どう
[音楽]
売っ
宜しくお願いしますよろしくお願いします
死者というしてもよろしいでしょうかはい
えー
ブーブー
僕のイメージなんですけど本店の従業員さ
んっていうイメージがありましたああいや
遅いありますね作家ホテルじゃないんだ
ことじゃじゃあ家にいてもを貸してくれる
はいそうです
[音楽]
here are
真実ポリピュア清手配師と予約入っており
ますまじっすかーさーいっプロフィール見
て熱あるんですよねそうですね
プロフィールがありましてそれを鮮烈公開
させていただきます早くでようやく具合
まあなどに喧嘩なきゃいけんよとやるな
時間緊張するなぁプロフィールにどうか
結構大豆というそうですねもう
ブーバーしてる cell 4本と白
サティ僕がそのサービズ利用させて
いただくとしたらめっちゃくちゃ可愛い
女の子の声で起こされたり道
そういうこともいろいろすぐのわー
いわゆるアイドル a マジただし直接
電話くることは少ないですあさあなんです
ねそうないは機械が電話していきますので
やっほぉ
1せいでだけはい実演じゃないんですから
ねこんな感じでやりますって言うもう
ちょっと用事てきましたので行ったまあ
これセリフまあそれぞれ用意して
いただければいいかなと思うんですけど
これを俗やつです構成合意これ名前が表示
されてますよねこれは嘘じゃないこれを
読んであげるのもポイントですならた仮に
名前が花子さんだった場合はなりました
はいでたくさんおはようございます中の人
斎藤ですおめざめいかがですか今日は2月
18日金曜日です荒木んですそれでは今日
も元気にいってらっしゃいませんこんな
感じ
印鑑とキュッとしてますねそうですねで
これは正各個人によっても色々アレンジし
ていただいたい中にはもう完全に
モーニングコールじゃない人も
いるんですけれどもこれサイトは池田過去
話をカットされて売ったりするととも言う
らしいですね
パティただいている
atis けども
[音楽]
ブーバー生5位で狭い焼き刃の寂しいかに
モーニングコールさっきバスからのいけ
ないモーニングコール女性四年となります
ねはいじゃあ女性量だと思いますね男性も
これですよね胸からの前向きなモーニング
コール如意彼から名前モーニング7時から
のモーニングコールずやっぽい金からの
ic モーニングコール
ブーバー
し一路
ステッ
だからちょっと銀座でしたこの基星町に
入ってる良薬ですので配合元気を振って
くださいわかりました今日はながら音何日
でしたっけやばいめっちゃ近所席ソファに
車に来るちょっと寝てるかどうかわから
ないですけど
相まってもスペルこそ
kayo さんおはようございます中の人
肇社長ですおめざめいかがですか
おはようございます今日は2月の18日
金曜日
ハナキンでございます
それでは今日も元気にいってらっしゃい
ません
5らっしゃいませんありがとうございます
がんばれー
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーバーコンビのん仕込みなんですけど私
のコンビニめちゃ厳しくて1はず会とか
結構なニットホテル版よりなんですよ
仕事となると相手が走る人はちょっと
わかってると思いますのであそっか全部だ
と言ってもいいですけどあじゃあ次は
ちょっと待ったーいて帰って今ちょっと
割とお客様っていうそんな感じじゃあ今日
純的な次はポッツさんはじめ社長を出して
行きたいと思いますはいいきますね今回お
願いしますいきます
智仁さん
伊藤さんおはようございます中の人肇社長
ですはい
おはようございますおめざめいかがですか
はい今日はですね2月の18日金曜日
花の金曜日でございます
はいぜひ今日も全然元気いっぱいに頑張り
ましょう
伊藤弾いってらっしゃい
けど
うんっ
平敷さんありがとうございましたーーー
って感じこれで完了であればいいんだいや
何か
てくれると嬉しかってすぐ出てよくて
よかったとかなぜな役なんちなみになん
ですけどもういいバーでバイトといえば
ちょっと気になるところというから
だいたい稼げるというかまぁ仕事的には
どんなぐらいなんですかこれ
ブーバーまあ冠馬レバ
にょろ下がると予想ですねモーニング
コールが欲し事で番台てだったよって言う
奴と知らなかったんだけど
貴重な経験をさせていただきますこの後札
社大学ねはいありがとうございました
はいというわけで次のアルバイトはですね
おうちで出来るアルバイトでございますご
時世的にも家の中でできるアルバイトも
もちろんありますので今回その一つをご
紹介したいと思いますなんとするをオール
アルバイトでございます
こんなのあるんやすごいですね釣れたり
折り紙を折って作るツールなんですけれど
もでもこういうこと起動ネッツにじゃあの
バイト始めさせていただきますっておうち
で折り紙で鶴を折る区アルバイトがある
らしいですただずっとこれあるという方が
不定期にあるみたいな感じらしくでずっと
音が募集してるわけじゃないらしいんです
けども一応暗示際するあるバイクです
ネットで見たらなんか値段がだいたい位
市はおりとな9っていう情報見たって実際
に道路値段つとよくわかんなくてやっぱの
状況とかに応じて値段変動するような気も
しますが今回あの市場俺と7円で樹形観山
してみたいので1時間
するおりだと思いました
折り方分かりません
では早速折り鶴のアルバイト始めていき
たいとおもいます良いスター
とよりもわからないからちょっとネットで
調べたから見ますねまずなんか国おります
やっぱお客様にあげるってことですから体
でよらないといけないんだろうなさらに
もう1回三角に折ります
おっ供給で何か見えてきたぞこうやって
おります
うわちょっとダムなんかすごく2の武器は
でにがてっというかあんまり得意ではない
かもおりますはい開くとおり雪ができます
って何言ってた視力って言うんですか
やばい最後は攻めて移動すればいい
d
むずいぞ
ちょっとあったぐっ
むずこんなむずいってやばいえっ国が経過
しました
今ココです
した
[音楽]
大きいを記念号なんかわかったよ
こういうことか
何か見えてきた見えてきたら
[音楽]
やっと一はできましたはっはー
あー10分徒歩たいやーめちゃくちゃ遅い
からこのページですけどちょっと頑張り
ますあと50分
[音楽]
はいというわけで1時間が経過しました
最初は折り方すらもちょっとわからなかっ
たんですけどもだんだんスピーカーがって
言って一時間後結構を作りだと思いますよ
ご覧くださいこちら2いっ
[音楽]
123456789ずっ
時給
70円
いやあの分かっているんですった俺が遅い
んですもうそ新車だからこんなペースなん
ですけど1時間70円いやもう完全に速度
が遅いの当然でてっ月も遅いし完成度も
委縮いんですけどもまぁ私本気を出させて
いただいて1時間でな杖このアルバイトで
かピークを買ってきましたがすごい人は1
か月で慎吾ジャックはを得られる方も
いらっしゃるみたいで
ht 2時間がやったとして1ヶ月で
ツール俺だけで10,500円活性化れる
方もいらっしゃるみたいですのどういう
ページなんだろう俺みたいなこのチンタラ
やってると絶対そんな稼げないんでもう
これホントここですね9色と言いますか
キュア目たら俺ももっと速くなるんです
けどもうちょっと現場は時間
羽はじめ
皆さんこんばんは次のアルバイトはこちら
お化け屋敷でございます
お化け屋敷のパイとって何だろうって全然
に皆さんもおったと思いますよ俺も
ちょっとわかんないんじゃまたな異常なん
ですそうなった
なんで下がったというかどういう仕事され
てるのかって本時僕は気になりますしやっ
てみたいとも思うのですが楽しみなんです
けどもあの元全北大津とそのオーバー景色
が苦手なものでして僕ここまで来たこと
ないお化け屋敷ので結構のビビってます
けどもまずはお客様の気持ちになること
それが大丈夫ということで1回体験してみ
ますねー
嘘からですよね
ただバイトするだけじゃないですよねー
てきます
えっ
まぁ最初の表ございますわー
バーだけて誰がー
ウリだんです翌日は吠え道
ブーバーこちらでです猫映像を見て
いただきます映像を最後までご覧になって
から左手を擦りくださいございました
さっきますああああああっ
50部方へ
虐待を受けていたちーちゃう小学校で息を
引き取ったまじかー
かな w
もうアムウェイを橇ベレー
まじかこれこれアルバイトの動画だよねー
強い屋根部
p ええええええじゃあ会は誰を取れじい
ちゃんとオーラじゃない
ち違う
しません
ブーバーレジャー
ヌー
her ear
パーバー
ええっ
ああああああはぁっはぁっはぁっ
すごい
ここでの撮影は終了です
ありがとうございましたん
はいというわけでただを合計式に来たわけ
ではありませんってかダンダラ入る必要
なかったんじゃないでしょうか今回はこの
おまけ式のアルバイトいうことでしっかり
と化け屋敷のお仕事とはどういうものなの
かなっていきましょうよろしくお願います
ua
ああああああああああああ
ブーバー式のプロデュースしております
斎藤村ビット申します斉藤のぞみさん今日
はよろしくお願い致しますそれだけど
パティにいろんなお仕事があるけども
ゾンビというかハァハァぬーっにょして嘘
としたいですよじゃあ肇社長様ために狂っ
な演出と
用意しましたませんかそれねありがとう
ございますそれを
やってみましょうぜひいらっしゃいます肌
やり方なんですねが味の社長さんにはは
まずこの膜の違うに隠れてもらいまあこの
地がですねあの撮ろうとしたら
お客様がこっち側からできますのでここの
場所でお客様はおふだを置いて成仏して
くださいっ
いうミッションをやってもらいますそれを
言ったらここのライトが連符
消えますこれが消えると真っ暗闇で何にも
見えない状態になりますねお客様自身も
手持ちのライトを持っているんですがその
ライトも9万は真っ黒なのでそれを貼っ件
力で消えてただ明かりが一箇所だけあり
ますそれがここです
ここのライトが
お客さんがを少しここを照らしてますので
なのでお客さんだけちょっと照らされて
いる状態に肇社長さんはここ一帯が真っ暗
になったのを分かったら
幕からねくってお客さんの位置と距離感を
しっかり
のみてください
ならわかりますが手をどかすタイミングは
僕があのインカムであ同じはい合図が来
たらスイッチを on にしてやる
化して
ライズブッシュリフト届かず時は oo
このあの空気が出るしずーっとエアだった
ありますのでもう演出は1歩1歩増えて
ないけど触れられたような感覚に合うで
から先すごいなぁ曲がったんだちょっと
多いいけどぴゅろすぞ
いう記事
ゆうゆうホンダんです
与えられた場所 d
与えられたショット
確実に子です
リーガー
おばけのバイター
ちっっを開けて抱いてるけど
どこに進め良いねーっ
わからないですいい
[音楽]
[拍手]
ドアを開けてどこ
ああああああああkan
いわばいやバイバイ
emeん
えっ
そこへ暗すぎる見えないまったく
じゃぜひとりちゅううう
チャックしますね
ウール anuhea
いやー艦これは
なんか
あっああん
んん
あっ
あっあああーーカーチョませんでっおり
これが合計9分成仏してください
はカンナわかんないミッションとか本当に
寒させたままてきてる米とついてない
ライトついてないないとついてないん
とっ
しんちゃんのそうなチームがあった
ちょっとだけのでじゃあ
意識はい
rehacer
ああああああ
nan
混ざっ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
あっあっーひで坊どうでしたあははい
とてもよかったと思うからねそれここまで
来る間にとてもお客様がいい状態になって
たのでお皿に肇社長との僕とのコラボの
こと歌詞もすごく効果とのが良かった
なんてて最高でしょお客さん日実績 air
見られながらヤるまっすぐ結核
いらっしゃればでそうですねドッキリだ月
なんだよな筆頭を出せるんあっなんか
ちょっと性にあってるよすごいやりがいを
感じるお城
さあ
はい時で今回は僕も皆さんもあまり知ら
ないようなアルバイトちょっといろいろ
経験させていただいたんですけれども全部
に言えることは楽しかったですもう全部
楽しかったけどやっぱジャンルというか
全部もちろん大変なことだったんですけど
もいろいろジャンルが違ったりなマイクロ
2本とだんだん心から大好きな生き物と
ふれあえる他の人だったけどの接客業と
いう大変さお化け屋敷はもうほんと1
オードガスで歌の下だけども見せれないと
いうその緊張感モーニングコールもその
相手のことを思いやったような気持ちよく
朝起こすという風の気遣いとか千羽鶴の
そのもうほんと効率のよさとかどうなる
場合も楽しかったけども大変なことがあっ
たらって今日順次いろんなアルバイトをし
て思いましたけどすごい楽しくて充実して
おりましたでーすーがー
皆さんなぜアルバイトをするかと言います
ともちろんやり方が仕事が楽しいとがある
と思うんですけどももちろんお金を稼ぐ
ためにやれていると思うんですよそこで今
バイトルですねリップインティ
プロジェクトというものを行っておりまし
てどういうものかといいますとバイトルの
社員さん達が自ら足を運んで各企業山にず
きゅアップの混走されているみたいです
バイトルの中には上野のバイトがあったり
時給が高いバイトの特集なども行っており
ますアドバイスをされている方ならわかる
と思うんですけどもなかなか給料を上げて
くれるとかですごいいいじゃないんですよ
そう勾配てるからやってくださっていると
いうことでみんな球場高いに越したことは
ないようなアルバイトをしたことから私が
分かりますやりがいもすごい大事ですでも
やっぱり時給がいいとか待遇が良いとか
そういうのはすごく大事だと思う人はそれ
によって結構やる気とかモチベーションも
上がると思うので私このディップ
インセンティブプロジェクト応援しており
ます金がほしいと勇気でバイトルのアプリ
なんですけれどもこちらいろんな上限で
バイトを探せるんですけどももちろん行き
レディアだったり職種給与そしてこちら
バイトインセンティブですね口数に給与
アップのがありますバイト霊言的には決定
するとこんなちゃんの企業がいま給料を
上げようと努力しているということで
ございます凄いそしてこちらの画面に職種
もすごい選び放題なのできっと皆さんにし
たい職種アルバイトが見つかると思います
のでぜひ探してみてくださいはいという
わけでさっき見たと思うんですけども
dip インセンティブプロジェクト本当
に素晴らしいプロジェクトだと思います
所持ギアがアルバイトしてた月
思っていたのは本当給料も上がったらすぐ
嬉しかったんで働く環境を良くしようとし
ている企業の皆さん本当に素晴らしいと
思いますは学者数見せそう水休アップ応援
団として需給アップさせる企業の皆様を
応援します本当に素晴らしいと思うので
詳しい内容はどんなも概要欄からチェック
してみてくださいなんか久々にバイトし
たくなったじゃ
dl
[音楽]